hey guys happy tech Tuesday I'm so
excited about this episode because this
week is something extremely special it
means a lot to me and I think that it
might mean a lot to you guys if you guys
participate in the project that I'm
going to talk about here in a minute I
will tweet all of you guys back who
tweet me that say that you participated
so this week December 8th through
December 14 I'm partnering with
Microsoft and co.org in their hour of
code now it's crazy to me because for me
growing up computers weren't as advanced
as they are now but it was something
that I've always loved
I was super passionate about and I know
most of you guys watching this video
because I see your tweets I know the
kind of videos that you guys like and I
know that you guys love technology as
well so I am so excited about this
because coding is such an important part
of our future it's an important part of
today it's an important part for me
because I would not be here if it wasn't
for coding and technology I mean the
camera that I'm using somebody had a
code this thing to work YouTube hello
before I start rambling it off on some
crazy tangent if you guys want to
participate you can go to Microsoft comm
slash hour of code we have all kinds of
little fun projects some of them are
really easy some of them are a little
more difficult I did the flappy bird one
was pretty easy it was really fun so
pick out a project complete the project
anytime this week tweet me some proof
and I'll tweet you guys back and if I
don't reply back the first time keep
tweeting until your response so why does
it mean so much to me is I had no idea
of what I wanted to do when I was in
school my mom was always like just
eating so what you're gonna do with the
rest of your life and I'm like I don't
know I love computers I love technology
in sixth grade I taught myself to code
HTML I bought visual basic books I
bought JavaScript books I bought all of
these crazy books and that was the only
thing that I wanted to do I wanted to
learn to program and then when I got
into high school I never had your
typical part-time job because I was
always doing sort of like little graphic
design projects I was making websites
for people so I knew sort of all through
high school even though my mom was like
just seeing what are you gonna do it was
gonna be something with computers when
high school I took every possible class
that I could that had to do with
computers even though I don't like math
I took the computer math classes because
they taught us basic Visual Basic C+ C++
and taking those courses it was awesome
to be able to see how these programs
actually work but I found out my true
love which was actually designing the
front end
interfaces I'll never forget I think
when I turn to you one of my programs
and the teacher was just like you're
come it's ok just seen but this
interface looks really awesome maybe you
should consider becoming a designer and
that's when I was like you know what
you're right I know a lot of you guys
are still in middle school you're going
to high school or you're going to
college or you're already in college or
you're a full adult already out there
working it's never too late to learn
this stuff it's such a good skill to
have
it's just something awesome that I think
that people should know how to do and
not know it to the extent that you can
create your own social network right
here in the next 25 minutes after doing
an hour of coding and I know a lot of
people that are in school that really
aren't sure what they want to do and
it's it's an option there's gonna be
such a huge demand for people that know
how to do this stuff so if you're stuck
if you're confused even if you want to
become a youtuber just have something
else there has to be something else that
you can do I thought you guys to not get
too stressed out about what you're gonna
do in the rest of your life because I've
had several career changes everyone does
it's fun it's scary but that's what
growing up is all about this is sort of
been my motto throughout my entire life
I like to be good at a lot of different
things not the best at one thing but if
you're not good at a lot of different
things be the best at one thing anyway I
just love technology so much and I would
love to be the person who has introduced
coding to one of you guys or five of you
or 10 or 20 or hundreds or thousands and
then one day down the road many many
years later you guys can come back to
means they just seen I remember when you
made that video about coding and now
guess what I'm a computer scientist I
have created the next social network I
have created the next really cool app so
don't forget make sure down the road you
guys come back I'll be waiting for that
high-five again check it out Microsoft
comm hour of code please please please
please tweet me when you guys finish
your homework I look forward to seeing
which projects you guys do bye
[Music]